this man is a compadre of mine you can
check them on NFL Network on Twitter
also at 89 Jones NT AF right I get that
cursor ntam is it okay for me to ask you
what that stands that means never think
about failure okay yes well because you
know I mean I know what AF means to some
people on Twitter so I just want to make
sure and you can check out James tonight
on NFL Network's NFL power rankings at 6
p.m. Eastern Time and then Wednesday on
NFL Total Access at 7:00 Eastern good to
see you sir see so we were just chatting
in the television only segment about how
you were what number receiver were you
coming out of to the combine the hundred
and thirty second wide out rated so
which means that I probably wouldn't
even been invited to the flag football
tournament that was going on it I felt
Network this path but I had a very good
combine came out of the combine number
32 then after my pro day moved up to
16th and I was the 13th water I'll take
it 13th
wide out taken okay you have the 12
other ones a 2007 okay second overall
pick Calvin Johnson Harvard 9th overall
pick Ted Ginn jr. Dave gift okay that's
right though okay 23 overall dwayne bowe
yep dwayne bowe 27th Robert Meachum
oh thanks Kim 30th overall Craig Davis
Buster Davis yep LSU 32nd overall
Anthony Gonzales you ran for it okay got
it
44th Sidney Rice 45 Duane Jarrett
Dewayne Jarrett
51 the other Steve Smith Oh from us yeah
the Giants took him right went to the
Giants right 73rd Jacoby Jones
Toby now this guy with all due respect
I've never heard of him 74th
llaman figures you want figures I
remember he ran for two at the cowboy I
did not well I mean over the first lady
27-yard 75th overall Laurent Robinson I
learned of Falcons Lana Falcons from
Illinois State 76th Jason Hill Niners
Niners from Washington State James Jones
78 chosen by Ted Thompson taya Tom's
okay Mike McCarthy and Mike McCarthy
then all of a sudden you show up and
Brett Favre's throwing you past a farmer
stormy past you remember the first pass
recall from Brett Farr I remember first
pass I dropped the very first pass
because I you know me and Aaron you know
when I first got there we were on the
second team so you know I'm catching all
the passes from Aaron Rodgers and then
coach said okay man you're going in with
the ones and I'm like all right man this
is just catch the ball when it come your
way and the ball looked like it was
coming so slow and it hit my hands so
hard and I batted it down and I dropped
it and I in my head I'm like he's never
thrown me another pass again man my
first first time there's just you know
go out here catch a pass ran a very good
route no play need a ball that's good
and I dropped it and in my head I'm just
like he's never gonna throw it to me
again
if Favre say anything you were he just
smiled at me and you know as I came back
in the huddle and I'm like ah that's the
smile he ain't gonna throw it to me
again and in the very next play he gave
me another opportunity and I caught it
so I'm like okay cool we must like me a
little bit okay there you go
see now interestingly enough James Jones
here on the Rich Eisen show is that lost
amongst this conversation that McCarthy
and Rodgers have irreconcilable
differences that their relationship
isn't broken that's the narrative that
we're seeing this may be true ish
more not true at all but to me they
clearly are not happy with each other I
think that's the way it is that a fair
assessment to say that's what it looks
like okay
lost amongst all this is McCarthy's the
one that that took the heat for ending
along with Ted Thompson and everybody
else the Favre era in Green Bay to hand
Aaron Rodgers yeah his opportunity and
that's it seems like that's so long ago
that it doesn't matter between the two
men anymore is that a fair
assessment no it matters I mean and I
talk to people all the time cuz you see
what happens on the football field I
mean they both competitive they both
saying stuff hand gestures and all this
like they you know really don't like
each other but coach Mike and Aaron's
relationship is it's like a marriage
you've been married for 15 years and
you're gonna argue you know what I mean
that's gonna happen but if your wife is
cold you gonna make sure she get a
blanket you gonna make sure she warmer
she go if she hungry you gonna make sure
she gets some food and that's coach Mike
and Aaron's relationship like they're
gonna bump his but they love each other
I mean you should see these dudes at
practice I mean they cracking jokes with
each other all the time you know what I
mean hugging each other on it I mean
they they buddy buddies and coach Mike
always said controversy is good you're
supposed to disagree supposed to fight
family fights you know what I'm saying
but at the end of the day we love each
other we both trying to win and I think
when you see him and Aaron on the
sideline and you see Aaron and him
barking back it it's at that competitive
they're trying to win they communicate
every week they meet Aaron coach Mike
every week together you know what I mean
so that relationship is good I like it I
mean because I've been there firsthand
and seeing how they communicate with
each other and it's not how a season
seems on to eat so it's not it's not as
bad as what it's being trotted out not
at all not at all huh cuz you know Aaron
doesn't they don't even seem to be
talking to each other during the game
you know like how many times did we see
just and again where we're sitting at
home and we just the narrative we get is
always see from the pictures we see on
the screen yeah three and out six and
out nine and out whatever it is no
points three points or whatever Rodgers
will just sit down and I'll grab his
he'll grab the the tablet or not or just
stand there with the helmet on and
staring in space and we're all thinking
he's hating life or something no doesn't
because I mean since so interpreted yeah
all my years playing him in coach Mike
never really communicate on the field he
goes and sits down he communicates with
the dude with the quarterback coach
that's on the sideline he's gonna
communicate with the offensive
coordinator and coach Mike so coach Mike
never really comes over there in access
in what are you seeing on the field you
know what are you trying to run things
now he goes to the quarterback coach so
talk to the quarterback coach let's try
to do this let's try to do that then
they'll communicate on the headset
mic and that's how it's always been so I
mean I'm not surprised where I mean
he'll come off after a touchdown driver
after a three and out after interception
to come and just sit down because he's
talking to the quarterback coach that's
how it's always been in a quarterback
coach a related message hmm so then what
is give me the the full scope from you
James Jones cuz we just had Greg
Jennings on yesterday listen Greg has a
different approach as to what he thinks
the Rodgers coach Mike relationship is
if you refer to McCarthy that's what I'm
saying I mean I feel like it's a true
marriage man you're gonna fight
sometimes you're gonna argue but at the
end of the day when I see these guys
communicate during the week and see
their relationship during the week it
shows no nothing that man I don't like
this guy or I hate this guy and you know
what I mean I want this guy out of here
it shows none of that
Aaron ain't even came up to us and said
man I don't like Mike and this and that
and I mean he comes up and tells us a
lot of stuff now he may come up and say
man we need to try to do this coach Mike
needs to call this and do that but their
relationship there's nothing wrong with
their relationship they're both trying
to win Aaron Rodgers I mean even Aaron
Rodgers took a lot of heat for some of
the hand gesture she gives to some of
the receivers and things like that but
we know Aaron we know he's trying to win
we're trying to win some time we'll give
them back but it's just two competitors
trying to win and like I said if it was
happening during the week I practice
where I could see them them not
communicate and not talking to each
other Aaron over here coach Michael over
here but during practice they're talking
24/7 and that's what we stands next to
him practice he'll go over there to
coach Mike and practice and make sure
everything's also what's wrong with this
team they're not making place and it's
hard it's hard to put it on the coach I
mean you're losing by two points in the
Rams game to a very good football team
your defense has played a very good game
they have 24 points you're about to get
the kickoff you fumble that has nothing
to do with the coach it's 1717 Aaron
Jones breaks a nine yard run you're in
the red zone in New England you fumble
then last week termal Williams comes up
he runs up for a punt to catch it ball
hits him you know Aaron Rodgers misses
Devante on a wide-open throw it has
nothing to do with the coach you know so
I like coach McCarthy as our head coach
the Packers are just now making play
especially in times in crucial times of
the game where you need to make plays
and that's causing them to lose all
right I'm gonna then I'm gonna press
press you on on the the the one major
seemingly wide held narrative about
McCarthy is the play calling is just
dreadful I mean the play calling
stressful like on a fourth and inches
that they go for a dive that they aren't
scheming anybody open that it's just
like go get open an errand I'll just run
for his life long enough and make some
gorgeous throw that you don't see coming
because it's against the grain of his
body blah blah blah is that a fair
assessment than in your this this all
happens when you're losing when you're
losing you gotta find something to put
your finger on I remember I mean this
with the idea that you wouldn't be
losing if the scheme was better the
season we were 15 and one we were
blowing people out we were just line up
and we would just play and we will make
place we lost one game in Kansas City
they beat us up just hit us in the mouth
and everybody's saying Oh coach
McCarthy's offerings he didn't move
people around it's the same office we've
been running you know I talked to
Davante Adams
Adams a lot he's like listen it's not
the offense it's us not making plays
like we turn on the film on Monday and
we watch these games it's not skiing
wise like people are open its holes at
the running back back to hit and make
some plays like it's not that you know
I'm saying we're just not making plays
and even me being a coach mic system for
eight years it's a very good system
specially for a quarterback and a wide
receiver that's why I'm even though
Aaron's great but he's putting up
special numbers in coach Mike system
like it's a very good system to be in
well right now they just not make it
plays and that's all it comes down to so
then the final button on this subject is
to Brian gudykunst and Mark Murphy you
would say what when they have a decision
to make seemingly because you know that
Packer fans many would like to see a
change in head coach grass is not always
greener on the other side and I would I
would stick with coach Mike I'm looking
at our young defense play they're
playing lights out right now they
playing some ball and Rodgers in them on
the offense are not playing go football
right now they need to score points they
at least should be scoring 30 points
every now and then and they're not a 14
points 17 points that's not that's not
gonna get the job done I will keep coach
Mike um change change is not always good
I mean you got a very young team very
young often so you bring in a new
offensive coordinator these rookies and
young guys got to learn another offense
when Aaron Rodgers new signals would
enter Rogers it's kind of like you
starting all over I will keep Mike Mike
has a good thing going over there and
even schedule-wise like the schedule
coach mike has for the Green Bay Packers
right now is lovely a lot of rest a lot
of recovery is it's a very player
friendly schedule you get a guy coming
near like a Jon Gruden like like I
talked to Jordy that's hard-nosed you
out there at practice you guys might not
respond to that you know so no what do
you mean whatever about what Jordi's
telling you just like you know coach
Gruden practices is real hard grimy
practices you know what I'm saying you
coming out there you and pads you're
hitting each other you know it's it's
hard you know what coach Mike no pads on
you know recover get your body back
right you know what I mean and it's not
like that everywhere so you bring that
in and yet sometimes culture change is
good but when you've been used to
something for so long and you get
changed you might not respond to it like
that I like coach Mike coach Mike has
done some great things in Green Bay and
I hope we keep so we're having not won a
game on the road yet this year and word
is this week is that McCarthy frequently
lowers the number of stars associated to
a hotel establishment with each passing
road loss
are they intense now are they in a
lean-to right now they might be in a
motel five right will Blackmun tweeted
out said he tweeted out in oh wait when
you guys lost four straight road games
he made sure each hotel got worse if you
want to stay in a nice hotel he said
quote win a damn game absolutely and
will is 100 percent correct man we were
we were staying at the Holiday Inn
expresses the motel flies and at the
time as players were thinking like okay
you know it could be some stuff going on
you know I mean maybe might be MB a game
could be a concert it was availability
like stuff might just be going on we
used to stand and I know the
ritz-carlton in these 5-star hotels up
come some could be going on and then it
kept happening and we like what's going
on man we ain't got no room service you
know we got nothing over here and he say
hey win a game you know I'm saying and
things will change she's doing that
right now I don't know I don't think
he's doing that right now you might need
to know cuz we woke up we said look
we're trying to get no bedbugs and all
that we we woke up and start to play us
a football you might need to put him in
the motel file yeah I mean their next
road game let's see their next road game
for Green Bay is gonna be at Chicago
oh I mean there won't be an availability
problems in the city of Chicago great
establishments there I put them in the
motel five of Chicago would it be cold
out there in New York in New York so
just keep yeah so if they were in a
Chicago game and you treat them in New
York you Pacific well they'll know
they're in trouble for the jet game if
they're staying in Pennsylvania they'll
know that they're in deep trouble at
that point in time ask the poll question
of James Jones and the poll question is
brought to you by house hunters
celebrate the season with special
holiday episodes of America's nightly
fix which is house hunters only on HGTV
house hunters home for the holidays just
in time to deck the halls and celebrate
with loved ones surprises you have to
see to believe this new twist on a
network favorite will not disappoint the
holiday season only on one only one
winter house can win this holiday season
home for the holidays premieres Tuesday
November 27th 1980 central on HGTV ask
the question of James Jones Christmas
yeah James who's the biggest threat to
the Chiefs in the AFC Chargers Patriots
Steelers Texans themselves oh that's a
very good question right there I would
have to say the Patriots just because
the Patriots have already beaten them so
they kind of know how to play them they
understand them nothing's gonna catch
them by surprise
the only thing is is you might have to
go play them in Kansas City but I think
Bill Belichick and Tom Brady can get it
done because they already have and they
kind of know what it takes to get the
job done see what I'm saying is the
Patriots are the biggest threat maybe to
the Chiefs because they have the
tiebreaking
get the Chiefs on a plane to play in AFC
Championship game now that would be a
big threat to the Chiefs but I think if
the Chiefs get New England there
don't you think it the way that the J
that the Patriots seem to be playing
right now like if that game was played
right now an arrow and I don't think it
would be close personally I think it
would not close because I I really can't
see that defense stopping Tom Brady and
net offense now the Jets the Jets put
them in that's division game division
games are always tough no matter what
the record is I mean we used to go to
Chicago and we used to be 13 and 2 and
Chicago one and one and 13 and come out
of there looking at fourth-quarter 77
division games are always hard but
Kansas City cannot stop the pager
especially if you got you got a healthy
Rob Gronkowski out there I don't think
they could stop them so I think the game
will be a lot closer huh then you think
but the Patriots will have to get one or
two stops you know from Kansas City to
and that's that's gonna be hard to but
this Sony Michele edition is huge for
for for the Patriots it keeps them
balanced it can it can keep Patrick
mahomes and a dolphins off the field and
Tom Brady never could score some points
I think they're the biggest threat yeah
here's three 100-yard games the most
matches for a rookie of the three
previous 100-yard games that they've had
from a rookie running back of the entire
Belichick Brady era he's a he's a good
player he does change the dynamic what
is the what is the what are the results
as they currently stand I will start at
the bottom texans 8% steelers 10%
chargers 17% themselves 24% patriots 40%
see i chose themselves I know you put
your right no I chose themselves I think
that they're the only ones who can stop
no and you're right about that I think
if they turn the ball over that's it and
hurt themselves pre-snap panel yeah
that's a minute two minute sequence
clock mismanagement that sort of stuff
but when you say Michelle I mean he's
been terrific so is Nick Chubb okay and
the Browns very good yes well hold a
minute the Browns are as we discussed
yesterday in the hunt they're in the
Ottoman technically
peripherally in the hunt okay by the way
great album I don't know who sang
peripheral what album was peripherally
in the hunt Talking Heads maybe I could
have been peripherally in the hunt was a
great what
Roxy music maybe right doesn't that
sound like the Roxy music any rate went
down a wormhole there sorry Jana but
what did you think of the Baker Mayfield
handshake stuff
everybody's got a a take on it I'm
wondering what you thought I mean I'm
good with the handshake like okay you
don't want to come in for the lovey
dovey stuff and all that you know what I
mean
but I mean it let me know the
relationship to him and you have but I
just wanted him to come on the podium
and say listen me and he was
relationship one like that or that's
between me and Hugh you know what I mean
and not answered a question but you
can't come up there and say well he left
Cleveland and Wednesday he got fired you
know what I mean usually when you get
fired you go looking for another job if
somebody offers you a job you take that
job
players get cut all the time come back
play their former teams all day P
teammates want a Jersey swap and all
that you showing them love you know what
I mean so it's not like you just walked
out the building and said I quit you
guys stink I'm out of here I'm going to
Cincinnati so I just what she would have
came up after the podium like that's
between me and Hugh you know our look
Mia Hugh's relationship ain't like that
I shook his hand there it is there you
know ain't gotta you ain't got to be
best buddies and giving hugs and I don't
know I just think he's of a different
generation there James and and he's also
feeling it and I think what what he's
about is being himself and being genuine
on behalf of the people in the locker
room that's the way I took it to mean
that he and the folks in the locker room
thought that Hugh might not have been
all in or he was about himself a little
bit as much as it was as he was about
the team or at least that was the sense
and so when he and was asked a direct
question he wasn't gonna give you the
usual you know what that's between me
and him and he might get there at some
point of his quarterbacking career but
right now at this moment a feeling - let
players know players know the motives of
the head coach players know so yeah
absolutely I trust well if Hugh was in
there and he's you know giving this
message but doing this I mean players
definitely
since that do you know what I mean so
like I said that's what I'm saying like
that showed me the relationship they had
and they did that showed me that they
did not have a good relationship yeah
but you can say it was it was an
extended handshaking and he was going in
[Music]
you pointed out yesterday with the head
tap when he went in for the dog and
realized he wasn't gonna get it so with
the extended hand for the hug he just
tapped him on the head she was like me I
shook
no-one's hand after the game whether I
knew you whether you went to San Jose
State I had darted off the field to the
showers every single game home why away
I'm just like man if you got my sea you
got my cell phone number you could call
me you know but I never was like I'm for
the goal here shake everybody's hand
after did you know Jersey changed well
coach Mike came in and locker room
mm-hmm
I was already shower ready to go likes
most of the times I beat the media out
there like a lot of times they had to
like grab me and say no you have to talk
today James but I you might come in
there he'd give his speech win or loss
you know and I already you already
showered already I just got tossed my
clothes on and get up out of there by
the time the media comes in there I'm
already out me and a family on the
highway so no Jersey exchange no not
well Green Bay you can't Jersey swap
what do you mean our jerseys are not
really Nike jerseys our jerseys are had
the Nike checks sold on them uh-huh but
they're made by a company in Green Bay
so it's not like we could just swap our
Jersey and they call Nike and say send
me another Jones Jersey like our jerseys
if we get a hole in them yeah you get it
sold up you know what I mean and you
know so you only have a handful of
jerseys during the seasons so if you're
right so these guys on a massive road
losing streak they're staring at the
stars at night you got to go to Mars
Mars is the best seems just in the world
your name is more just sew it up for you
and the cheese isn't the only thing with
holes in it
Wow see
there you go that's James Jones some
quality information at 89 Jones NT AF
which stands for never think about okay
we're gonna make sure about that and see
James tonight on the Power Rankings show
on NFL Network 6:00 Eastern then
Wednesday total axis 7:00 Eastern love
to have you sir anytime always always
enjoy our chats it's James Jones here
well when we come back great old gent
stat from last night wait to hear it
quality stuff 844 204 riches in the
number doll
Scott Boras will be joining us as well
coming up on the Rich Eisen show to talk
about the price Harper hot stove the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience